Now its main event time
I give you your incredible
We know each other? He's a friend from work
Surprise surprise everyone asking when they're going to drop the thor trailer. They just drop it out of nowhere
So we see everything from hell the destruction of Thor's hammer and hope Vs thor in the arena
He's a friend of mine
We know each other from work, so let's break this down, but if you're new to the channel
I do marvel and DC every week, so be sure to subscribe to get it
There's going to be a whole bunch of thor happening this summer
And I'm doing a giveaway that I'll explain at the end of the video
So [just] starting at the beginning of the trailer working our way to the end so thor narrates as he's being dropped down into hell
hell is the domain that hella as you could imagine rules over she has the ability to call a portion of
Asgardian souls not every soul because some of them go to valhalla
The others go to her there's been several times in the comics where thor has been at her Mercy?
So they might treat it a little differently in the movies, but in the comics. It's like an actual different plane of existence
it's not just [like] a planet that you could go fly to
The other option is this could be a stand-in for fire
Lord sergers realm which is like a completely different place from asgard, but we don't know if he's going to be in the movie
There's just a big fire demon looking creature in the concept art they showed at comic-Con
So that is probably where this comes from but it's either a hell, or is fire lord servitors realm which are two different places
So you can kind of judge the timeline of the movie based on Thor's haircut, so when he's being drop-down in here
He has like the full classic haircut
So this is probably earlier in the movie you see hella walk up with the torn pants then you see thor on Earth
throw the Hammer at her hurt catch it and
Destroy it so that explains
why he doesn't have his hammer on Sacar and why it looks like he has a
Different version of his hammer like the ultimate thor hammer or even yar bjorn his giant axe and the other
Concept art that we've seen so just expect him to wield a couple different weapons during the movie
But I think we all expect him to get a version of his hammer back by the end
but for infinity war really, this is all just to show you how
Powerful Hella is compared to thor you have to remember the reason. He's on Earth is because he's looking for odin
He has long hair in the doctor strange post credit scene, so this might be
Some time around that when they're still looking for him because in the comics
Odin is the one that was powerful enough to banish hella to hell so with him absent she runs ramp
All this craziness where it looks like they almost destroy all of asgard or turn it into another version of hell
We can think loki for that they explained it as he's been pretending to be odin
He does such a terrible job at ruling that she escapes prison, and that's how this happened
So it's not like he purposefully releases her
but he's been trying to be king this whole time so thor comes back ask them all these questions in Tom hiddleston's like
Yellow key does not give him a lot [of] answers right away, but look at hellas full headdress here
So just like thor gets a couple costume changes during the movie
She's going to get a couple
Costume changes to this trash planet is the car itself so it's a slightly different version from the planet Hulk comics
But this is what the grand master rules over and this is sort of where the movie goes mad max Beyond the thunderdome
Where valkyrie binds him and induct him into the game?
She's working with the grandmaster
But because she's an asgardian they have this interesting relationship like she's been hiding out on sacar
So it'll be fun to [find] out why she chose to work [with] him in what it is
She's going to do to help thor and hulk escape because we know this is like a buddy
Roadtrip movie with hulk and thor, but we don't know how much valkyrie works with them this shot
Here's of all the valkyries attacking her her taking them down that might have something to do with why the valkyrie
Character is on sacar. Maybe she's hiding out
She has a weird history with asgard because it seems like she's been there for a while
But sis is supposed to be in the movie, too
She might be amongst these people that are taken down
Because I don't know how big her role is I didn't even think that she was going to be in the movie
But she appears on the IMDb page, so I think Thor's chemistry is mostly going to be with valkyrie like there's no Jane foster
There's going to be no relationship. What's it as far as we've seen but hella
Just looks so badass with her sword here
There are a couple different weapons that she wields in the comics, but the main one is the knight's sword
It's made of uru metal just like thor's weapons better look at the car
I love to try to hear in the background everybody's wondering when neighbors going to Join the marvel universe
There's going to be a lot of easter eggs
And I know we're wondering who some of these helmeted people are they could be the eternals because they're definitely not the celestials
Loki very clearly sitting with the grand master here on this couch, and [you] look in the background, too
And this definitely looks like easter egg for [ihSan] the searcher one of the celestials
but because he's not 2,000 feet tall like I did the
Celestials Easter egg video this might be one of the eternals
Because the grand master is one of the elders of the universe it would make sense that he be hanging out with other very
Powerful people in the Galaxy so we'll see how they treat those characters in the movie
But the really cool thing about the eternals is that they were created by the celestials
So just more Jack Kirby stuff
and if you look at these designs in the background to this is also right out of Jack Kirby this wallpaper looks so awesome to
these designs
Maybe they'll start marketing that I feel like marbles production design is so much better in Phase 3 so much more beautiful
Looking the grandmasters men giving him the haircut
And we finally see him Jeff Goldblum as one of the other elders [of] the universe the Grand Master
It doesn't seem like he's being too crazy, so we'll see if he has any tied to the infinity gems
but in the comics
He's the one that has the mind gem phantoms has to come take it from him
but we know in the movies that
Vision has the mind gem so we'll see but as an elder of the universe of course he would know about the infinity gems
So he'll probably have something to say about it, so even though
He doesn't appear anywhere in the trailer just [expects] [anos] to be somewhere in the background watching all of this happen
I know a lot of you are wondering if hella is going to be the stand-in for death during the infinity Gauntlet Storyline
They actually [just] paired those two up in the comics like they're actually a thing now
[Danos] kissing hella because she wants to get her realm back. He can help make that happen
He's all about death she rules over death
So it would make sense that if they're going to do that from the comics then they would try to use stuff
They're already setting up and she's one of the most powerful figures in the McU now so we'll see about that
She's not confirmed for infinity war
But it would make sense is he such a big character that she would pop back up
Somewhere because you typically don't kill villains that are this big?
But we finally see heimdal trying to take down one of hell has been without his classic armor on then we see Karl urban scourge
For the first time who's working with hella in the comics scourge is one of the thralls of Amora the enchantress
And a lot of you are wondering if she's in the movie
I don't think she is just because she seemed so similar to what hell is doing in all this
So as always possible there could be an easter egg
But just a lot of storylines get compressed and given to other characters from the comics in the McU so hella might be
Absorbing a lot of other big characters like death in a more of the enchantress
I just love the idea of hella making her first escape and then taking on all of asgard by herself
Main event time so we see thor in his full battle gear
He's got his braveheart makeup on he's got a classic version of his helmet
I love the way he turns the little wings up like it is in the comics
and I give you your
Incredible hulk wearing his planet hulk armor so the cool thing about this in addition to like the funny moment where he's like
He's my friend from work talking about the avenger stuff back on Earth, but holt doesn't seem like he immediately
Recognizes thor so that's why they're fighting and there is this bloodlust that thor gets when he's fighting it just makes him crazy
I'll do another video about it later this week because [there's] a really important reason [why] he would bite one of his friends
But the way they talk about hulk in this movie
Is that he's been off the car for a while now fighting in the arena? He's their most popular contender
He's like a God they're so it's kind of gone to his head, but in these behind-the-scenes pictures
They've actually posted him as banner
So for those of you wondering whether he was going to be in hope for for the entire movie that should answer that I'm expecting
him to be hope for
most of the movie but not everything
Look you have the big third act it no [t's] any of that in this we don't see fire lords surgery
We don't see any of the other big ragnarok monsters. So they'll save that for the main trailer
Which we might get in another month or two so we'll see how long it takes
Most of this trailer is just meant to hype up the planet hulk elements of the film thor VS Hulk
Hella destroying most of asgard and Loki making his flight to sacar to find thor so that they can go find odin later in the
Movie so I'm expecting them to save some of those big things like odin himself all the big Ragnarok monsters for like that next big
Trailer if you're not familiar with the song they were using during the trailer to that's led zeppelin the immigrant song so that works on
A couple different levels hella is an Immigrant to asgard they literally talked about going to valhalla the asgardian version of Heaven
So they're just a couple different reasons. They use it in the trailer they talk [about] all the new lands
They're going to be visiting different corner of the marvel cinematic universe that we've never seen before in a very cosmic way
That's why they're calling a roadtrip movie with thorne hold so let me know what you guys think of this
I can't wait to see more James gunn even said that this is his
Favorite Marvel trailer from all the big marvel movies that are coming out this year
Even more favorite than his own guardians of the Galaxy 2 trailer which I think it's kind of funny
believe all your requests for thor Ragnarok videos in the comments below
I'll do a follow up video in a little while
But there is a new round of the spider-man giveaways for the action figures all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on this video so click here to learn about the big thor Ragnarok
Celestials easter egg, and you can click here to learn all about Darth Vader's castle, and what's going on during celebration later this week?
Thank you so much for watching let's high five. I'll see you guys in the next video